Okay, so let's go ahead and take a look at clients real quick.
So, this is the original test function that you had test1
and remember that you said that some of the behaviors that that doesn't test for
is basically all of these if statements here.
So, I'm going to go ahead and just try test2 to test these two main ones
that is if the size is equal to max, then we will return false,
and if the tail is equal to max, then we will reset the tail to zero.
So let's go ahead and build that. Okay.
So in test2, we create a queue of size two and we make sure that it is empty to begin with
just as a good start, and we enqueue1 and enqueue2.
We make sure that these both returned true.
And then we enqueue 3 or we attempt to enqueue 3,
which shouldn't work because remember it's only a queue of size 2--it can only store two elements.
So, we should be able to check that, and the tail, queue.tail, does not equal to zero.
If it doesn't, then we haven't reset it to zero like we said we did right up here, remember?
So, that would be a problem.
And we check that right there and, otherwise, we print out test2 as okay.
So, we go ahead and run this. Okay.
Now we see that we print out test2 as okay, so everything is good.
So now, let's go ahead and check out test3.
So for the third test, remember let's take a look at dequeue function really quick.
So, we want to test that when you dequeue an empty queue,
you should return none since there is nothing to return.
Then, we also want to check that if we dequeue and we have gone pass the end of the queue
that is the head pointer has stepped out into a larger element
and the total length of the queue, the size of the queue,
then we want to reset it to zero.
So, if we go forward or pass the end then we want to wrap it that around.
So, let's go ahead and take a look at test3.
Okay, so the first thing we do is we initialize a queue of one element.
So, it can only store one element. It's not a terribly exciting queue.
So first, we try to empty it, which shouldn't work. If it does, then we got a problem.
Then, after that, we try to dequeue and so remember this should return none.
If it doesn't return none, then again we got a problem. If it does, then we continue.
Now enqueue one element, so at this point, the queue is full
and head should be at one, which is the max size of the queue.
So now, when we try to dequeue, we should reset queue.head to zero.
If we don't, then we got a problem.
And we go ahead and check that the element that we get backed out from dequeue
is also one--just to be complete.
So, if we get through all of these, then we print out test3 okay.
So, let's go ahead and run that and we see that, yes, test3 is okay.
So, you might have tested different things.
You also might have tested just some of these and that's fine.
The goal was just to try to figure out different places in the code
that you could test against that we had already given you.
And that's a really important thing to learn how to do as a tester.
So, okay, let's go ahead and move on.